liv boeree mais comprenez quitter ou
rester dans l'union européenne
c'est l'objet du référendum qui a lieu
ce jeudi 23 juin au royaume uni installé
depuis 19 ans à maisons laffitte
la famille watson suit avec attention le
scrutin dans l'inquiétude on est un peu
stressé aujourd'hui parce que justement
on peut pas aller voter donc on peut pas
ajouter notre vote pour rester les
britanniques
habitant depuis plus de 15 ans à
l'étranger ne peuvent pas voter une
règle regrettable vraiment j'ai très
très déçu que on n'a pas un statut pour
pouvoir voter parce que ça nous concerne
plus parce que ça fait 20 ans qu'on
habite pas en grande bretagne quand on
habite dans l'union union européen
contrairement à sa mère christopher
watson a participé au scrutin
la raison il est actuellement domicilié
en angleterre pour ses études
sa position est claire le remake
politiquement je trouve que l'union
européenne à bout beaucoup pouvoir quand
même et on serait mieux de mieux
influencer les décisions si on à
l'intérieur qu'à l'extérieur en cas de
brick site
les conséquences peuvent être
importantes pour les britanniques vivant
en france notamment concernant la
situation administrative
est-ce qu'on va revenir à la carte de
séjour ben ça c'est pas très grave mais
c'est en en
on va encore plus loin que ça peut-être
et à tes questions est-ce qu'on peut
rester ou pas voilà comme la famille
watson de nombreux britanniques vivant
en france espère le maintien du royaume
uni si le choix se porte sur la sortie
les conditions seraient négociés pendant
deux ans entre le gouvernement
britannique et les dirigeants européens